A GOOD MORNING YOU ALL WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GET THIS
HEARING STARTED --
THANK YOU FOR COMING TO THE
MARCH THIRTEENTH MEETING OF THE
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING%
COMMITTEE.
BEFORE WE BEGIN.
I HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE FIRST
WHATEVER PLEASE ANSWER
CELLPHONES.
SECOND I HAVE A LETTER FROM THE
SPEAKER POINTING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO TO REPLACE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON FOR THE PURPOSE
OF TODAY'S HEARING ONLY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO WILL BE
JOINING US SHORTLY.
IN THIS COMMITTEE BILLS ARE
HEARD AND SIGNED IN ORDER
GENERALLY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BILLS ARE HEARD AT THE END OF
THE AGENDA UNLESS WE HAVE A
BREAK WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
OTHER AUTHORS TO COME TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM LIKE NOW.
BEFORE WE GET TO BILLS HOWEVER
OUR FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS WILL
BE TO ADOPT COMMITTEE ROLES --
PEOPLE DIDN'T DIDN'T THINK SO
WE'LL DO THAT AS SOON AS WE GET
A QUORUM --
SOUL SAVE ALL OF THAT --
IN THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WILL
OPERATE AS A SUBCOMMITTEE --
AND I THINK THE ONLY AUTHOR HERE.
THE MISTER LYLE.
HELLO YOU LIKE A PRESENT
[inaudible]
THIS
.
THE GREAT MISTER CHAIR IF I
MIGHT.
MISTER LOW IF YOU'D LIKE TO HOLD
ON ONE SECOND SORRY TO INTERRUPT
YOU IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A
QUORUM -- SO
MAYBE WE'LL GO AHEAD AND AND
CALL THE ROLL.
BERMAN.
I LIVE.
HERE [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
LOW HERE.
LOW HERE MAYES.
MAYES PRESENT MOMENT
[inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER HERE [inaudible]
RULES.
AND LOOK AT WE HAVE A QUORUM.
YEAH SO BEFORE YOU THE BILL'S
REALLY QUICKLY WE NEED TO ADOPT.
MANY ROLES FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE SESSION THE PROPOSED
MANY ROLES ARE SIMILAR TO THE
RULES USED FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
SESSIONS THE ONLY CHANGES THIS
YEAR WERE TO CONFORM THE RULES.
TO CHANGE AN ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY
SIX POINT ONE AND SEVERAL
TECHNICAL CHANGES AND
CLARIFICATIONS OR SUGGESTED BY
THE CHIEF CLERK.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
PROPOSED.
WITH A MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND.
WE ARE SECOND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE MISTER VICE CHAIR.
I DID A QUICK THING ON THE RULES
PLEASE SIR THANK YOU.
FOR JOINING US YEAH SERMON LATE --
NO PROBLEM --
SO I JUST WANTED TO STATE WE'RE
WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS ON THIS
COMMITTEE --
LOT OF LOT OF I THINK PRESS SEEN
IN IN GOOD ISSUES FOR US --
TO ADDRESSES HERE --
SO LOOKING VERY MUCH LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT --
YOUR JUST AS AS AS YOU KNOW WE
BROUGHT UP WE THINK THAT.
EVERY MEMBER SHOULD BE ABLE TO
BRING.
THEIR BILL AND HAVE A HEARING --
AND SO WE DO JUST HAVE THAT
OBJECTION.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT.
EVEN THOUGH I KNOW THOSE THOSE
ARE THE RULES AS PROPOSES THAT
WE WOULD.
ENSURE THAT EVERY MEMBER GETS
THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A BILL
THAT WE TRY.
TO WE TRY TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE A HERE AND I THINK THAT'S
THE ONLY RIGHT SO I DON'T KNOW I
MEAN IT'S NOT SOMETHING THE NEW
WE CAN JUST COMMIT.
TO EVEN THOUGH THE RULES SAY YOU
KNOW MAY AS OPPOSED TO SHELVE
SURE LET'S LET'S YOU AND I HAVE
A CONVERSATION.
OFFLINE I'M HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION NOT NECESSARILY
RIGHT HERE --
BUT I FULLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING --
AND AND DO APPRECIATE IT SO IN
THE END FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE
RULES THEY HAVE TO CONFORM WITH
THE ASSEMBLY RULES THAT WERE
ADOPTED --
BUT BUT I YEAH AND I JUST I MEAN
SO JUST FOR THAT REASON I OPPOSE
THEM YOU KNOW --
THE RULES BECAUSE I JUST WANT TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY.
JUST AS A MEMBER LOW IS HERE TO
PRESENT HIS BILL TODAY THAT
EVERYONE HAS THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO HAVE THEIR BILL HEARD
UNDERSTOOD WAS MISSING.
THE REASON I AM I MOVED IT AND I
DIDN'T VOTE FOR THE OF THE RULE
ON THE ON THE FLOOR BUT I HAVE
SUPPORT IN OTHER COMMITTEE I'M
ACTUALLY COMPLETELY FINE WITH IT
I DO THINK THAT THE CHAIR SHOULD
HAVE SOME DISCRETION SOMETIMES
ARE BILLS INTRODUCED.
THAT DON'T --
THE JUST DON'T NEED A HEARING ON
THAT I THINK.
I DON'T NEED A HEARING --
AND I THINK THE DISCRETION IS TO
THE CHARITY BILL DO THAT I DO I
DON'T THINK.
ON THAT THIS IS A PARTISAN
MATTER I THINK THEY'RE THEY'RE
DEMOCRATIC BILLS THAT THEY DON'T
NEED TO BE HEARD ON I THINK THE
REPUBLICAN BILLS.
AS DON'T NEED TO BE HEARD AS WE
NOTE SOMETIMES THERE ARE BILLS
ARE INTRODUCED FOR THE SAKE OF
SENDING OUT A PRESS RELEASE --
THAT I DON'T THINK THAT THOSE
BILLS NECESSARILY IF THEY'RE NOT
LEGIT OR NOT REAL AND THEN THEY
TAKE UP A LOT AN AWFUL LOT OF OF
TIME -- BUT
BY DO BELIEVE HOWEVER AND THAT
DOES NEED TO BE AS NEED BE
DISCUSSION OUT THAT I DO BELIEVE
THAT THE DISCUSSION --
THAT THE CHAIR WILL SHOW THE
TYPE DISCUSSIONS NEEDED TO
WARRANT WHETHER BILLS TO BE
HEARD OR NOT HEARD SO --
MAKE THE MOTION PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
AND WITHOUT FURTHER DISCUSSION
WITH A MOTION AND A SECOND.
MA'AM SENATOR.
MOTION TO APPROVE THE COMMITTEE
ROLES.
BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I GALLAGHER NO.
KAREN NO SANTIAGO.
LOW I KNOW I MAYES.
MAYES I MODE.
WEBER.
MEMBER I THE DOUBLE.
ELEVEN SO THAT'S A FOUR ONE VOTE --
SO THE COMMITTEE RULES ARE PROOF
BUT LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS SAT ON LATER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WHILE WE WENT THROUGH
FORMALITIES.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
PRESENT YOUR BILL YES --
MISTER CHAIR OF FROM MY DAD THIS
IS A CLARIFICATION A. B. ONE
SEVEN SEVEN ELECTION DAY HOLIDAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
STERN COLLEAGUES --
THIS BILL PROPOSAL IS WITH
RESPECT TO MAKING ELECTION DAY
HOLIDAY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE CURRENTLY
EIGHTEEN OTHER STATES IN.
THE UNION THAT ALREADY HAVE
ELECTION DAY AS A HOLIDAY AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT.
A KEY ASPECT TO ENSURING AS MUCH
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY IN
PARTICIPATION AS POSSIBLE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS YOU KNOW
HAS LEAD IN THIS EFFORT TO MAKE.
VOTING AS MUCH EASIER IN THAT
MUCH PARTICIPATE.
WITH RESPECT TO ALL THE ISSUES
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES TO ALSO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND ASK
THEMSELVES TO IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES FOR IT.
PLEASE.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BERMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DAN AL PER AND I AM A SENIOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY AND I ALSO SERVED AS
THE VOTE COALITION DIRECTOR. FOR
THE ASSOCIATED STUDENTS OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO DO
FULL TESTIMONY THIS TIME OR JUST.
JUST MONIES GREAT GREAT YEAH
OKAY -- SO
AS THE VOTE COALITION DIRECTOR
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY --
WHICH REPRESENTS THE
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND IN TOTAL ON
THIS PAST FALL I LED THE MAIN
VOTER REGISTRATION AND GET OUT
TO VOTE EFFORTS ON CAMPUS WHICH
LED TO THE REGISTRATION OF OVER
TWO THOUSAND NEW STUDENTS WHICH
WAS THE HIGHEST REGISTRATION
NUMBER ON RECORD. FOR MID TERM
ELECTION AT UC BERKELEY --
I'M HERE TO SPEAK BRIEFLY TO ALL
TODAY --
BECAUSE THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF
THE MID TERM ELECTION SEASON --
I NOTICED A LARGER MORE
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM TO VOTING I'M
ESPECIALLY FOR STUDENTS THAT I
WANTED TO SEE ADDRESSED AND I
BELIEVE THE AB ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
SIX RESOLVE ONE OF THOSE
PROBLEMS.
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT MAKING
ELECTION DAY A STATE HOLDING
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA SO
HISTORICALLY LOW VOTER TURNOUT.
25% OF REGISTERED VOTERS
PARTICIPATED IN THE PRIMARY AND
42% OF REGISTERED VOTERS
PARTICIPATED IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION.
STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS SHOWN
DON'T VOTE IS A LACK OF TIME.
DATA AGGREGATED BY THE
WASHINGTON POST IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN THE PURE RESEARCH
CENTER IN TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
THE U. S. CENSUS IN
200-082-00012 AND OTHER NUMEROUS
ELECTION YEARS.
HAVE ALL FOUND THE COMMONLY
CITED REASON FOR NOT VOTING WAS
BEING TOO BUSY OR HAVING A
CONFLICTING WORK AND SCHOOL
SCHEDULE.
A TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN
TOUGH SURVEY ALSO SHOWED SIMILAR
RESULTS FOR STUDENTS
SPECIFICALLY AS THE MOST
COMMONLY CITED REASON AMONG
YOUNG REGISTERED VOTERS FOR NOT
VOTING WAS AGAIN HAVING
SCHEDULING CONFLICTS.
I COULD SHARE CITY EXIT
STATISTICS WITH YOU ALL DAY BUT
WHAT'S JUST AS IMPORTANT AS
THESE NUMBERS OF THE PEOPLE
BEHIND THE STATISTICS THE PEOPLE
OF THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHO DESERVE THE TIME IN THE
SPACE TO EXERCISE THEIR CIVIC
DUTY.
STUDENTS ARE NO EXCEPTION TO
THIS CONUNDRUM YOUNG PEOPLE IN
FACT HAVE ONE OF THE LOWEST
VOTER TURNOUTS OF ALL AGE GROUPS.
ONLY ONE IN FIVE STUDENTS
REPORTED VOTING IN THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN MID TERM ELECTIONS.
I COULD SHARE WITH YOU A
MULTITUDE OF STORIES FROM MY
TIME IS VOTE COALITION DIRECTOR
IN WHICH DESPERATE AND FRANTIC
STUDENTS CAME UP TO ME ON THE
DAY OF THE ELECTION LAMENTING
THE FACT THAT THEY DID NOT HAVE
TIME.
IN THEIR SCHEDULES TO WAY AT A
POLLING STATION TO VOTE.
A TYPICAL NARRATIVE COULD BE
HAVING A MID TERM ON ELECTION
DAY ALONG WITH THE REST OF THEIR
CLASSES AS WELL AS A SIX HOUR
WORK SHIFT AT LEAST TWO EXTRA
CURRICULAR COMMITMENTS ON TOP OF
MORE HOMEWORK.
COMBINED WITH THE FACT THAT
THEIR POLLING STATION WAS NOT
WITHIN WALKING DISTANCE OF
CAMPUS MEANING THEY HAD NO TIME
TO GO OUT AND VOTE.
CREATING AN ELECTION DAY HOLIDAY
WILL REMOVE A SERIOUS BARRIER
FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS WHEN
STUDENTS DO NOT HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT FINDING ENOUGH TIME TO
VOTE ON ELECTION DAY THEY'RE
BOTH MORE APT TO VOTE AND BETTER
INFORMED ABOUT THE VOTING
PROCESS.
EVERYONE DESERVES TO HAVE AMPLE
TIME TO VOTE VOTING IS THE
BEDROCK OF OUR REPRESENTATIVE
DEMOCRACY AND ONE OF THE MOST
CRUCIAL WAYS FOR THE ELECTORATE
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE
POLITICAL LANDSCAPE LANDSCAPE OF
THEIR CITY.
THEIR STATE AND THEIR COUNTRY I
IMPLORE YOU TO VOTE YES ON
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN AND
SHOW THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
THAT YOU CARE ABOUT THEIR
ABILITY TO EXERCISE THEIR CIVIC
DUTY THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAVE CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
PROVIDING MORE ACCESS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE IS KEY
INCREASING VOTER ENGAGEMENT
VOTER TURN OUT.
OF INCREASING BETTER ENGAGEMENT
IN TURN OUT IS FOSTERING CIVIC
PRIDE IN CREATING A CULTURE OF
CELEBRATING DEMOCRACY MAKING
ELECTION DAY HOLIDAY.
SEALS HE RECOGNIZES THAT
EXPANDING POWERFUL AN ESSENTIAL
WAY TO CHANGE WHAT IS POSSIBLE A
POLICY BY ELECTING ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERS.
WHO AN OFFICE MATTERS BUT WHAT
COMES BEFORE THAT IS ENSURING
THAT EVERY CALIFORNIAN HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE?
BECAUSE AMONG THOSE PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO VOTE ON
ELECTION DAY DUE TO SCHOOL OR
WORK OBLIGATIONS ARE PEOPLE
WHOSE VALUES INCLUDE DEFENDING
CLEAN AIR CLEAN WATER AND IN
ELECTING ENVIRONMENTAL
CANDIDATES.
AB ONE SEVEN SEVEN NOT ONLY
REMOVES ANOTHER BARRIER TO
VOTING BUT IT SHOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA IS COMMITTED TO
EMPHASIZING. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT TRADITIONS OF OUR
DEMOCRACY CURRENTLY EIGHTEEN
STATES AND PUERTO RICO MAKE
ELECTION DAY HOLIDAY AND IT'S
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO JOIN THE
STATE'S AND MAKING POLLS MORE
ACCESSIBLE.
ON ELECTION DAY.
AND AS WE CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE
THE VERY REAL AND DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND AS
WE LOOK TO THE NEXT TWELVE YEARS
THAT WE HAVE LEFT. TO
MEANINGFULLY ADDRESS THIS THE
GREATEST CHALLENGE OF OUR TIME
WE NEED TO UTILIZE ALL THE TOOLS
IN THE TOOLBOX TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM EVERYONE ON
ELECTION DAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND TO HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PROMISE YES WE HAVE THE CITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISTIE
BELL MY HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF CAL NONPROFIT THE
POLICY ALLIANCE OF MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
IN SUPPORT.
THANKS.
GOOD MORNING CENTER BREYER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES A SUPPOSITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SONORA ADDITIONAL ESSES IN
SUPPORT WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
NOT QUITE OPPOSITION --
CONCERNS WINNERS YEAH YES DANIEL
SILVINO ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES.
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY ONE
NONPROFIT REGIONAL CENTRES
COORDINATE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
FOR ABOUT THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
THOSE SERVICES ARE PROVIDED IN
THE COMMUNITY BY NONPROFITS
USUALLY SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
HELP FOLKS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES LIVE WORK PLAY VOTE
IN THE COMMUNITY.
OUR ISSUE WITH THIS IS THAT IT
UNINTENTIONAL INCLUDES A SECTION
CALLED THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SECTION SCHEDULE THE TO MULFORD
INSTITUTIONS CODE.
THOSE ARE HOLIDAYS THEIR
FURLOUGH DAYS THAT THE STATE PUT
FORWARD IN TWO THOUSAND NINE AS
ONE OF ITS BUDGET SOLUTIONS.
SO THERE MANDATORY UNPAID DAYS
OFF.
SO ADDING ELECTION DAY TO THIS
LIST IS OTHER FOR LOW DAY HONOR
SERVICE PROVIDERS WERE HOPING.
I AN ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR TO HAVE THE SECTION
REMOVED --
SINCE IT IS ACCIDENTALLY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
FURLOUGH DAYS HONOR SOCIETY IN
OUR COMMUNITY SO --
THAT GLAD THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON THAT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
CONCERN OR OPPOSITION.
SING NUMBER IN BACK TO
COLLEAGUES THIS MYTH.
THERE ARE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
IN IN CALIFORNIA DOES EVERY
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA PROVIDE FOR
A MALE AND A BALLOT.
BECAUSE WHEN I GET THE REASON I
ASK IS I GET MY MAIL IN BALLOT
AND I HAVE BEEN A PERMANENT
ABSENTEE BALLOT.
SINCE I WAS SOME FORTY ONE NOW I
THINK I WAS IN MY MID TWENTIES --
WHEN I WAS --
WHEN I STARTED BEING A PERMIT
MAIL -- BUT
THE ABSENTEE VOTER.
AND I GET MY ABOUT ALMOST A
MONTH --
BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
AND SO I'M NOT SURE THAT THIS IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE IF PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO THE POLLS THEY GET
THEIR BALLOT BEFORE THEY'RE ABLE
TO TURN IT IN SOME JUST.
WONDERING TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY HAS THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO GET A PERMIT ABSENTEE
BALLOT AND I'M NOT SURE THAT
THIS IS.
NECESSARY IF THAT'S THE CASE.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS ANY
VOTER CALIFORNIA CAN REQUEST --
BERMAN ABSENTEE BALLOT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS SOME POINT AND
AND AND I'LL I'LL SUPPORT THIS
FOR NOW BUT I THOUGHT AT SOME
POINT EVERYONE WE ABSENTEE
BALLOTS.
WITH THE REQUESTED OR NOT.
THIS ORDER CENTER.
SO IN KING COUNTY IS A MOVE TO
VOTERS CHOICE ACT THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT MODEL EVERY COUNTY
EVERY VOTER IN THOSE COUNTIES
GET THE ABSENTEE BALLOT NOT
EVERY COUNTY GUYS DON'T HAVE TO
MOVE TO THAT MODEL.
IT'S IT'S UP TO THEM TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT TO ARE
THE COUNTIES MOVING TO THE MODEL
OF THE VOTING CENTERS THE ALLY.
YEAH BUT I THOUGHT WHICH IS GIVE
THEM.
MANY DAYS A HIT TO VOTE YES THAT
THAT WAS THE ONLY THING I
THOUGHT AND I'LL I'LL.
NOT SUPPORT IS NOW BUT I THINK
ITH THE KIND OF CHANGES WE'VE
MADE IN THE LAST --
I DON'T THREE TWO THREE YEARS
ALMOST MAKES THIS SOMEWHAT
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT WE DO HAVE --
THE VOTING CENTERS THAT ARE OPEN
IN DIFFERENT PLACES IN LIBRARIES
AND ALL KINDS OF PLACES THE
PEOPLE CAN BEGIN TO VOTE EARLY --
WE OF EARLY VOTING WE HAVE A
BALLOT THE CENTERS WE CAN DROP
THE BALLOT OFF AT THE LIBRARY
THIS THIS THIS SO.
YOU KNOW I AND AND SO I I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER IT'S IT'S NECESSARY
AT THIS POINT --
TO THEN HAVE A HOLIDAY THAT ON
THAT DAY BECAUSE IF.
WHERE THE HOPE IS THAT MOST
FOLKS WILL OF VOTED BEFORE THAT
DAY BUT ALSO THAT THERE WILL BE
ALL THESE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE WITH ITS SUNDAY OR
MONDAY OR SATURDAY WHEN PEOPLE
GO TO THE VOTING CENTER SELF?
AND I KNOW MOST COUNTIES IN
MOVING TOWARD IT IT IN SAN DIEGO
EVERYBODY GETS AN ABSENT
ABSENTEE BALLOT THEY CAN USE
THAT OR NOT BUT THEY GET.
ONE AND SOUL --
SO I DON'T EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS
AND THIS ISN'T AN EXPENSE OUT I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH IT COSTS TO
HAVE ALL THESE HOLIDAYS PAID FOR
THE AT THE STATE LEVEL.
ALL IN COMPARISON TO THE OTHER
THINGS WE'VE DONE SO I THINK
THAT MAYBE I SHOULD THINK ABOUT
THAT A LITTLE BIT OF BECAUSE
WE'VE DONE A LOT ALREADY.
TO OPEN UP THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE SO IT'S NOT LIKE IT USED TO
BE ONE DAY AND ONE DAY ONLY YOU
KNOW IT'S ALMOST A MONTH I THINK
THAT THIS ONE OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT THE PEOPLE HAVE.
ACCESS TO THOSE GROUPS NEW
VOTING CENTERS THAT ARE COMMON
TO PLACE BUT I UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR IT EARLIER BUT I'M NOT
SURE IF IT'S STILL STAYS THERE
TODAY.
AS ONE TO FOLLOW UP WITH I'M NOT
SURE THAT I WAS CLEAR --
TO THE VOTE THE VOTE CENTERS
THAT YOU REFERENCED SO SOME SOME
COUNTIES ARE MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION --
IT IT WE HOPE THAT ALL DO BUT
IT'S UP TO THE COUNTIES THE VOTE
CENTER SLASH VOTERS CHOICE MODEL --
IS VOLUNTARY FOR FOR COUNTIES TO
ADOPT THAT MODEL.
BUT FIVE OF THEM DID IT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND AND MORE
ADOPTING AND NOW [inaudible]
ANY ADDITIONAL [inaudible]
MS ROGER.
YES SO --
YOU KNOW ONE I WOULD JUST I
WOULD CONCUR WITH THE REMARKS OF
MY COLLEAGUE --
AS A MEMBER WEBER IT IS YOU KNOW
AS AS WE AS WE ARE MOVING MORE
MORE TOWARDS ABSENTEE VOTING AND
N. B. B. M.'S AND HAVING VOTE
CENTERS --
WHERE VOTING OCCURS OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME --
YOU KNOW IT SEEMS LESS AND LESS
NECESSARY TO HAVE YOU KNOW ONE
DAY THAT STILL TOTALLY DEVOTED
ONLY.
ONLY TO TO VOTING SO I THINK
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING.
TO CONSIDER I JUST I THINK IT IF.
IT MAKES KIND OF THE BILL I
THINK UNNECESSARY --
AT THIS TIME --
BUT JUST BE.
MIGHT BE A NECESSARY DOESN'T
MEAN THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE A
HEARING TODAY.
AND YOU KNOW AND I AND I KNOW
YOU TO BE A VERY THOUGHTFUL
LEGISLATOR AND I KNOW YOU WOULD
BRING UP A BILL --
AND AND AND SUBMIT IT.
HELLO UNLESS YOU BELIEVED IN IT
VERY STRONGLY AND I KNOW YOU DO
AND SO AND AND I'VE BEEN I'M
DEFINITELY YOU WANT TO HEAR MORE
FROM YOU WHY YOU THINK.
IT IS NECESSARY --
BUT YOU KNOW I GUESS THE OTHER
PART I WOULD I WOULD GET AT IS
YOU KNOW WE OFTEN GO TO THAT
TWENTY FOURTEEN CYCLE INSIDE THE
VERY LOW TURN OUT.
I'M SURPRISED WE'RE NOT HEARING
MORE ABOUT THIS LAST MID TERM.
RIGHT WHERE ACTUALLY --
IT WAS THE HIGHEST VOTING TURN
OUT.
I THINK SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT --
SIXTY FOUR POINT 5% VOTER TURN
OUT -- AND
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
WAS ACTUALLY HIGHER THAN EVER I
WAS ACTUALLY ON THE CHEEK A
STATE CAMPUS ON ELECTION DAY --
AND YOU KNOW STUDENTS WERE LINED
UP OUT THE DOOR VOTING --
ACTUALLY WHEN I WAS A STUDENT AT
UC BERKELEY AS AS YOU WERE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THIS MORNING --
I CAME AND TESTIFIED OF BELIEVE
BEFORE TRYING.
TO MAKE REGISTRATIONS AVAILABLE.
ON CAMPUS YOU KNOW SLIPPERY
SLOPE BE KAREN.
AND YOU KNOW.
BUT BUT THE REALITY IS I MEAN I
WENT TO UC BERKELEY I REGISTERED
TO VOTE IN BERKELEY --
VOTE IN EVERY ELECTION NEVER HAD
A PROBLEM VOTING AND AND GOING
TO THE POLLS.
AND AND ENSURING THAT MY VOTE
WAS CAST AND NOW WE HAVE
REGISTRATIONS ON CAMPUS YOU CAN
AGAIN YOU CAN VOTE --
THROUGHOUT ALMOST A MONTH AHEAD
OF TIME ESPECIALLY FOR AN
ABSENTEE VOTER YOU CAN.
YOU KNOW PUT THAT VOTE IN A TENT
SO I JUST.
IT'S HARDER AND HARDER TO
BELIEVE THAT YOU'VE GOT A HAT WE
GIVE PEOPLE TO TWO HOURS OFF OF
WORK -- YOU
KNOW THE EMPLOYERS HAVE TO
PROVIDE THAT --
SO I MEAN I THINK IT'S JUST
HARDER AND HARDER TO MAKE THE
ARGUMENT THAT.
YOU CAN'T POSSIBLY VOTE --
WITHOUT SO I THINK YOU THINGS IN
MIND I WOULD JUST DEFINITELY.
ENTERTAIN ANY ANY REBUTTALS THAT
YOU GUYS WOULD HAVE TO THOSE --
TO THOSE TWO POINTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU I THINK MR MAY IS THAT
IN ANOTHER POINT YEAH I WAS JUST
GOING TO TO SAY --
OF WELL I HAVE GREAT AFFECTION
FOR THE AUTHOR.
A CAN'T SUPPORT THIS TODAY --
I WOULD BE SUPPORTING IT IF WE
WERE IF WE DIDN'T HAVE A MAIL IN.
A PROGRAM --
AND WE ARE ALL EVERYBODY VOTED
ON ELECTION DAY I WOULD ACTUALLY.
BE THE ASKING FOR A STATE
HOLIDAY FOR ALL WORKERS I'M ON
THAT ON THAT DAY ABOUT BECAUSE
WE DO HAVE --
WE CREATED ALL SORTS OF WAYS AND
THAT FOR FOLKS TO VOTE I'M SO
TODAY I'M I JUST CAN'T BE
SUPPORTIVE OF OF THIS --
THANK YOU.
ANY CLOSING REMARKS.
YES SAID THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FOR THE FOR THE CONVERSATION --
PART OF THE ISSUE IS.
HOW DO WE IS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO LOWER
BARRIERS TO ENTRY SO WHILE THIS?
IN IN ISOLATION A WOMAN TO BE
THE SILVER BULLET WE ARE HEADED
IN THE DIRECTION TO MAKE VOTING
THAT MUCH EASIER AS YOU SEEN
WITH ALL THE TRAJECTORY OF
PREPAID POSTAGE OF APPS THE
BALLOT AUTOMATED VOTER
REGISTRATION.
SO THESE ARE THIS IS JUST ONE
ADDITIONAL SCHOOL TO CONTINUE TO
ALLOW FOR GREATER DEMOCRACY
GREATER PARTICIPATION SO IN
ISOLATION YES I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT OKAY YES WE DO ALREADY HAVE
MANY THINGS. TO ALLOW FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE BUT
THIS IS JUST AN ADDITIONAL --
ARROW IN THE QUIVER TO ALLOW FOR
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE MENTION
ABOUT.
THE NOTION OF OTHER HOLIDAYS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE SO
WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF AND OKAY
DAY AND WHAT HOW WAS THAT
RECOGNIZED TODAY WELL WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECALL HISTORY.
AND OKAY DAY OF SERVICE ALEXIAN
DAY HOLIDAY TALKS AND PROVIDES
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IN DUTY TO HAVE
A SAY WHY DO WE HAVE A WHOLE
THAT IS NOT JUST TO JUST TAKE A
DAY OFF.
BUT WHAT IS DEMOCRACY ABOUT WHAT
IS YOUR MORAL RESPONSIBILITY
WHAT YOUR OBLIGATION TO OUR
SOCIETY TO PARTICIPATE TO GET
OUT IN THE POLLS. TO HELP WITH
ELECTIONS AND WHAT IS AN
ELECTION AND THESE ARE THE TYPE
OF THINGS THAT WE NEED MON TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE SO THERE ARE
MULTIPLE.
BENEFITS TO AN ELECTION DAY
HOLIDAY THERE'S NOT JUST SIMPLY
ABOUT.
GOING TO THE ACTUAL POLLS BUT
ALSO HAVING A CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT IS OUR MORE OBLIGATION AS
ACTIVE CITIZENS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THERE ASSOCIATED
IMPACTS WITH.
RECOGNIZING AN ACTUAL HOLIDAY SO
AGAIN THIS IS JUST AN ADDITIONAL
ELEMENT TO INCREASE VOTER
PARTICIPATION BUT ALSO TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND DUTIES AND
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THROUGHOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR Là.
SO I SUPPORTED TWO IDENTICAL
BILLS BY --
THIS AUTHOR LAST SESSION AND I
WANT TO COME AND COMMEND HIM ON
HIS COMMITMENT. TO TAKING STEPS
TO MAKE OUR ELECTIONS MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO VOTERS.
THE STATE IS ALREADY TAKEN A
NUMBER OF IMPORTANT STEPS AS
WE'VE HEARD FROM TODAY --
AND ADOPTING --
THIS BILL PASSING THIS BILL WILL
SIMILARLY SEEK TO ENSURE THAT
WORK AND SCHOOL CONFLICTS ARE
NOT BARRIERS. TO VOTER
PARTICIPATION AND SO ON HAVE
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY WILL
YOU PLEASE STOP MOTION.
OKAY AND WE STILL NEED A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
I'VE GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND.
I'M SORRY PLEASE HOLD ROLE.
MOTION IS TO PASS A RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION.
BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER NO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
LOW I LOW AYE MAYES.
MAYES NO MULLIN.
MORRELL I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER AYE.
SAID THAT BILL IS OUT ON A FIVE
TO TO VOTE THANK YOU MISTER LOWE.
A AND WE'LL MOVE ON WE WOULDN'T
SEEING NO OTHER AUTHORS IN THE
ROOM WHO AREN'T ON THE COMMITTEE
MOVE ON IN THE STORY GALLAGHER
IF YOU LIKE THE PRESENT. TO
CONFRONT BOLDLY.
AB THREE TWENTY TWO AND WHILE
YOU'RE GETTING READY WALL --
PASSED THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WE'RE THREE ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TODAY I REMEMBER TO A.
B. FIFTY SEVEN BY SOMEONE NUMBER
LOW.
I'M NUMBER FOUR AB TWO NINETY
NINE BY SOME NUMBER SALAS AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED AS
DETAILED IN COMMON NUMBER ONE OF
THE ANALYSIS.
AND ITEM NUMBER SIX A. B. THREE
THIRTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
OBERNOLTE DOES A MEMBER WAS TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MADAM SECRETARY WILL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BERMAN HI FOR ME I
GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER AYE
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I LOW.
LOW I MAYES.
MAYES I MODE.
WHEN I WEBER [inaudible]
MEMBER I THAT IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT ON A SEVEN TWO
ZERO VOTE AND MISTER ICE YOUR IF
YOU LIKE.
TO GO AHEAD OF THE POSITION.
SURE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
HONORED TO PRESENT AB THREE
TWENTY TWO TODAY AT A AND
COMMITTEE --
A BILL I THINK IT'S VERY
NECESSARY --
AND A GOOD ADDITION TO
TRANSPARENCY --
IN OUR OUR CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAWS.
YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW. FOR ALL OF
US IS CANDIDATES WHO WHO HAVE
RUN FOR STATE OFFICE --
ANYBODY CAN GO ONLINE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S WEBSITE.
AND SEE WHO HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
OUR CAMPAIGNS AND AS WE GET INTO
THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR REPORTING
PERIOD THEY CAN SEE IMMEDIATELY.
YOU KNOW WHAT --
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE MADE IS
LEADING UP TO THE ELECTION.
AND I THINK FOR THE PUBLIC THEY
FIND THAT VERY USEFUL. TO SEE
HEY WHO IS WHO IS CONTRIBUTING
WHAT WHAT INTERESTS MIGHT BE
CONTRIBUTING TO VARIOUS
CAMPAIGNS AND INITIATIVES --
BUT AS AS WE KNOW IS THAT DOES
NOT APPLY --
TO MANY CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT
DON'T POST --
THEIR CAMPAIGN FINANCE
INFORMATION ONLINE AND THIS CAN
BE PROBLEMATIC MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC --
MUST FIND THE RIGHT GOVERNMENT
BUILDING IN EACH JURISDICTION --
GO THERE IN PERSON MONDAY
THROUGH FRIDAY DURING NORMAL
FIGURE OUT WHO IS WHO IS.
NEIL GET COPIES OF THE ACTUAL
FORM -- FOR
SIXTY AND YOU KNOW BOB SHOULD I
THINK IT ALSO BURNS A LOT OF
COUNTY TIME.
YOU KNOW FOR THE PEOPLE HAVE TO
FIND THOSE DOCTORS BRING ABOUT
MAKE COPIES.
SO I THINK WE CAN DO BETTER YOU
KNOW IN TODAY'S DIGITAL AGE WITH
TECHNOLOGY --
IT SHOULDN'T TAKE MUCH TIME OR
EFFORT -- TO
EITHER TO SCAN AND POST THESE
ONLINE -- OR
UTILIZE SOFTWARE THAT WOULD YOU
KNOW PROVIDE THE SAME THING THAT
WE HAVE ON THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S WEBSITE --
AND SO MANY MANY LOCAL IN THIS --
BUT YOU KNOW THIS AB THREE
TWENTY TWO WOULD REQUIRE THAT
ALL LOCAL JURISDICTIONS POST
ONLINE IN SOME FORMAT --
THE FOUR SIXTY FORM SO THAT
EVERYONE CAN UNDERSTAND AND AND
EASILY ACCESS THAT INFORMATION
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AS WELL.
AND I DO HAVE A HAVE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY JOE PATTERSON --
THE MAYOR OF A NEARBY ROCKLAND.
AND ALSO DANIEL NEWMAN --
FROM MAP PLAYS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S JOE PATTERSON I'M THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF ROCKLIN --
NEARBY WELCOME YOU ANY TIME.
PRIOR TO ME BEING ELECTED THE
CITY COUNCIL IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN I WILL I WANT TO CITY
HALL AND ATTEMPTED TO I HAD
ACTUALLY WALK INTO CITY HALL TO
LOOK AT THE FORMS AND I HAD TO
ASK FOR THE BINDER --
IS A VERY AWKWARD SITUATION
BECAUSE I AT THAT TIME I DIDN'T
HAVE ANY SUPPORT OUR FANS IN THE
CITY -- ONE
NOW I'M HAPPY TO BE MAYOR AND
SINCE I'VE BEEN ELECTED THE CITY
COUNCIL ONE OF MY THINGS HAS
BEEN INCREASING TRANSPARENCY IN
THE CITY.
AND SO EVEN THOUGH SOME WOMEN
GALLAGHER IS NOT OUR ASSEMBLY
MAN I THOUGHT THAT THIS WAS A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL TO BRING TO
OUR CITY SO WE'VE SUPPORTED IT
AS A CITY COUNCIL.
AND WE DID ASK OUR CLERK BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT EXACTLY IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THIS BILL YET BUT WE DID
ASK OUR CITY CLERK ONE WE WERE.
HAVING A DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL
WHAT'S THE BURDEN TO DO THIS.
A SIMPLE HIRED A SCANNED THE
FORMS SENATOR REID TAKE AS PRIDE
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES SO --
SO WITH THAT IT'S HARD ARGUMENT
TO MAKE THAT WE SHOULD DO THIS
AND WE WILL IMPLEMENT THIS IN
ROCKLIN.
EITHER WAY BUT I THINK EVERY
JURISTIC THANK YOU THEY MISTER
MAYOR RICHARD.
HOWEVER MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DANIEL NEWMAN I'M THE CO FOUNDER
AND PRESIDENT OF MAP LATE.
WHICH IS THAT CALIFORNIA
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO ADD THAT THAT WE ADVANCE
GOVERNMENT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I'M
TESTIFYING IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL
AB THREE TWENTY TWO AND IT WOULD
HELP USHER IN AN ERA OF GREATER
TRANSPARENCY. FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
WITHOUT MUCH BURDEN AT LOCAL
CAMPAIGN FIND REPORTS OUTLINED.
WHO IS CONTRIBUTING TO LOCAL
CAMPAIGNS AND HOW THAT MONEY IS
SPENT?
AND CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW
REQUIRES THAT LOCAL AGENCIES
MAKE THESE REPORTS AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC BUT MOST GOVERNMENTS
FORCE PEOPLE TO REVIEW THE
REPORTS IN PERSON AT A
GOVERNMENT BUILDING TO THROUGH
IT IN THE CASE THAT THE MAYOR
SAID.
RATHER THAN PUTTING THE
INFORMATION ONLINE WORK ME
ACCESS MORE EASILY AT TWENTY
SIXTEEN REPORT FROM THE
NONPROFIT GROUP COMMON CAUSE
FOUND THAT 70%.
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES REQUIRE AN
IN PERSON VISIT TO THE CITY
CLERK ANOTHER GOVERNMENT OFFICE
THE MOST CITIES DON'T HAVE THEIR
INFORMATION ONLINE CRITIQUE THAT
REPORT.
L. CROSSES STATE OF COURSE
CALIFORNIANS ALREADY USE THE
INTERNET TO REGISTER TO VOTE TO
DEPOSIT CHECKS TO STAY UPDATED
ON THE NEWS PRETTY MUCH FOR
EVERYTHING.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO ACCESSING
INFORMATION ABOUT WHO IS FINDING
THEIR LECTIN OFFICIALS IN THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
PEOPLE ARE DENIED REASONABLE
ACCESS TO THIS UNLESS YOU CAN
GET YOURSELF TO A GOVERNMENT
OFFICE DURING BUSINESS HOURS
WHICH IS PRETTY MUCH IMPOSSIBLE
FOR PEOPLE THAT WORK WILL HAVE
LIMITED TRANSPORTATION.
AND AS A MAYOR NOTED IT'S NOW
TRULY EASEL TRIVIALLY EASY TO
POST A DOCUMENT ONLINE YOU JUST
SCAN IT AND POST IT.
AND SO MAKING THE STRANGE CHANGE
WILL BE STRAIGHT FORWARD FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND IT'LL HELP --
NOT ONLY WILL IT HELP MAKE
VOTERS TO MAKE MORE INFORMED
DECISIONS TO BE MORE ACTIVE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES BUT IT'S ALSO
AN EASY WAY TO INCREASE PUBLIC
TRUST IN GOVERNMENT AT ALL
LEVELS.
BECAUSE TRANSPARENCY DOES
CONTRIBUTE TO TRY PLEASE TO PASS
THIS IMPORTANT BILL AB.
THREE TWENTY TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
OUR MOTION.
WITH THE SECOND --
BEFORE WE HAVE A MOTION THE
SECOND AT AND BEFORE WE MOVE ON
OTHER ONE IS JUST WANT TO
CONFIRM WITH THE AUTHOR THAT.
YOU'RE OKAY WITH TAKING --
THE AMENDMENTS IN COMMON NUMBER
SIX OF THE ANALYSIS.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN WE'RE
ACCEPTING THE MOMENT SERVANT
BRIGITTE.
MOVE AS AMENDED GOT A SECOND --
AND LET'S MOVE ON TO AN
ADDITIONAL ONE THIS IS IN
SUPPORT YES SIR MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAUL YOUR SHUTTER INTO
WE HAVE THE BI<c.cyan> COUNTY BOARD</c>
SURPRISES ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ACCORDING TO MANY MEMBERS TRENT
LÏNG PRESENT CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN GREAT BILL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WOULD BE PROUD CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYWAY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL MOVE IT TO
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE AT WE HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND --
MISTER VICE OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE I WANT TO SAY I I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK OUR VICE
CHAIR. FOR BRING THIS BILL FORD
WHICH I WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE
WITH HIM IS A NECESSARY.
BILL.
THE BILL WILL PROVIDE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY FOR LOCAL CAMPAIGN
DISCLOSURE FILINGS BY IMPROVING
THE ACCESSIBILITY OF THOSE
FILINGS.
I ALSO THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT OUTLINED
COMING OVER SIX THE ANALYSIS TO
ENSURE THAT THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S
CURRENT RULES GOVERNING THE
REDACTION.
OF CERTAIN INFORMATION FROM
CAMPAIGN DISCLOSURE OF WITH THE
AMENDMENT I'M RECOMMENDING --
AND I VOTE AND ALSO --
WITH THE AUTHORS --
PERMISSION WOULD BE HAPPY TO IT
SIGNED ON AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE
BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD
ABSOLUTELY GREAT LOVE HEAVY
ONBOARD BRIGITTE YEAH --
SO WITH THEM AND SENATOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AND AMENDED RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE.
BERMAN AYE GALLAGHER AYE
GALLAGHER AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I LOW.
LOW I MAYES BY.
MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
WITH THAT THE BILL IS OUT ON A
SEVEN OF A THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU BRIGITTE.
AND I SEE WE HAVE --
MISTER SALAS.
IN THE ROOM --
FOR AB.
SEVENTEEN ELECTIONS OBAMA
BALLOTS [inaudible]
WILL MOVE.
WE'VE GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND
MISTER SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER TWENTY MEMBERS
THINK FOR THAT MOTION I WILL
JUST SIMPLY k
FREE AND FAIR ELECTIONS ARE THE
CORNERSTONE OF DEMOCRACY AB
SEVENTEEN ALSO KNOWN AS VOTER
PROTECTION ACT WOULD ADDRESS
VOTER COERCION AND PROTECT
BALLOT INTEGRITY.
AS DOES NOT OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR NINE THAT ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OF US IN ONE YES
PLEASE.
HI IF SOMEONE TO LONG ON BEHALF
OF SECRETARY SAY ALEX BY THE END
FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ANYWAY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
SECOND THIS IS ALSO BE LIKE TO
CLOSE --
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHORS CONCERNS --
AND IS PROACTIVE EFFORTS TO
PROTECT VOTE BY MAIL VOTERS
AGAINST UNDUE VOTING INFLUENCE
IN THE WORKPLACE AND FOR THAT
REASON I AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY --
MADAM SECRETARY WILL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
VERSION NEW PASSION RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN AYE.
BERMAN AYE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
YOUR HONOR I LOW.
LOW I MAYES.
MAYES NOT MONNING. ONE MORE ON I
WEBER.
RIGHT.
YOUR BILL IS OUT ON A FIVE TO
ONE BUT WE'LL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS RIGHT THANK YOU --
SHOULD BE A FIVE ZERO IT WAS A
FIVE TO ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SO -- YES --
MEMBERS OUT ON YEP SO LET'S.
GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON WHO WEREN'T HERE.
START WITH THE COMMITTEE ROOM
AND WE'LL START WITH THE
COMMITTEE RULES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO I MULLIN --
COMMITTEE ROLES.
ARE YOU AND I MON I THE
COMMITTEE RULES ARE APPROVED ON
A SIX TO ONE VOTE.
AND THEN I THINK WE JUST HAVE.
GALLAGHER --
AB.
SEVENTY AND THEN WITH --
LET'S OPEN BY NUMBER --
FIVE ACTUALLY I'M NUMBER ONE AB
[inaudible]
SEVENTEEN GALLAGHER.
YEAH ONCE ON CONSENT.
AND SO --
I'M FOR WAS ON CONSENT.
SO WE SO THAT'S OUT ON A FIVE TO
ONE VOTE.
IN DOING ANY OTHERS THAT.
ARE OPEN.
NOW WE SHOULD BE GET ALL THE
OTHERS.
GREAT [inaudible]
YEAH. TO MISTER SANTIAGO OVER ON
CONSENT CALENDAR.
YES ONE OF THE OTHER BODY
EVERYBODY AT CAN YOU THE BILL
FOR THIS MONTH.
WE CAN'T REQUIRE FULL FULL.
WILL GET TO IT.
SO I NUMBER ONE WE'RE GOOD.
I DON'T AGREE WERE GOOD.
RIGHT I'M NUMBER.
FIVE YEAH WE'RE GOOD AND THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND THE RULES AND THIS IS ON THE
ON THE PERFECT.
YEAH YEAH.
NO NOT AT ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH EVERYBODY THE HEARINGS
ADJOURNED [inaudible]
YOU CAN